[Music]  imagine a device that is the fastest  most advanced complex piece of  technology in the world  but what if it wasn't just a device what  if it was your new best friend  hi introducing the bee bot  it connects you to the world like never  before  express yourself imagine  without limits  create play and enter a new  world of friendship the bee bot  let's make friends wow  happy late birthday barney oh dad you  got me what  they toss the dice  hi insert registered name i am your  your your my bee bot  be bought  there's something wrong with it it's not  meant to do that i'm not meant to do  that  i am for making friends does barney need  friends well yeah or fun fact he will  not survive middle school  [Music]  i am insert registered named best friend  out of my box  [Music]  god  you